all right christian slater asked if you
knew a three of dracula's superpowers
what did you get jonathan we put
shape-shifting yep uh we we put we
thought you could read minds
and then we could hypnotize people read
minds hypnotize sort of the same answer
it's not we molly the [ __ ] saying
what's wrong with you you you massive
overpaid prick listen
you know who you look like in profile
brando
oh
marlon brandon yeah towards the end i'm
not kidding
[Applause]
she's so sickening
yes kennedy you know kennedy is i know
every single one they all do the same
move they drop down and do the splits
that's what i think when i'm watching
your shows too you know all the same
stuff
pete davidson's here
i'm appalled that people would come here
and make jokes about the sacrifice
pete's heroic father made on 9 11. this
is not the roast of pete davidson's
father that was in 2001
oh i was dumb wow
by the way dude that was you that was
your metric for i'm not that fat i'm not
ralphie mae
you can't come against me i was on your
side well yeah yeah
there's only one burger left no you're
not fat but you could you're overweight
you're overweight
but the uh it's it's the the you're
fighting the commerce and it's a
multi-billion dollar i need to i need to
paint you a picture of the commerce
right i understand the commerce is the
leader right but if you can tell a story
that's what food revolution was about
right which got an emmy by the way
shamone um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you get an emmy this year no we
weren't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the other legendary thing about
little kev is he has the dick the size
might be like hey and it's like hey and
he just goes look i got a big dick
[Laughter]
boy oh boy did you talk to him yet no i
don't talk to dummies
[Music]
hey look i'm a big fan of your earlier
work before the talkies i mean
god god bless you
yeah yeah be careful with them he's he's
spiteful he doesn't have the good guy
you don't want to dress up like that you
need the job i mean
god bless you know you're very good in
this are you really you really are sir
you're a legend i loved you in toy story
oh i'm thinking of tom hanks
i've been nice but the man's trying to
make his turn on me no you're right you
were being nice he was beating and
taking it i can have him unplugged
i'll leave milan did frank ever say that
to you i can have them on franco you
know who i'm talking about
this is the new york times bestseller
list not the new york news
yes new york times bestseller list and
by the way i didn't i got the new york
news rather than new york daily news
well that's great
anyway
that's don michael's channeling me god
bless don rickles i love him so much i
know it's in my fiber uncontrollably so
on friday i talked about uh youtube
gaming is a new youtube platform on
which people who play video games can
watch other people play video games and
of course i made fun of this because
there are people
watching other people play video games
which to me seems ridiculous but
apparently i touched on her because i
got an avalanche of mostly misspelled
vitriol over the weekend
we posted this video to youtube and it
has more than 52 000 thumbs down which
is a lot of thumbs down when it gets to
60 000 the police put you in protective
custody so
this is the most disliked video we've
ever posted to youtube and we've posted
thousands of videos to youtube and the
comments section is absolutely
incredible uh well let's go through some
of these these are real comments from
you stupid fat boy i guess that's me
people love watching people play video
games you're just mad because you will
be jobless in a one year you stupid
bearded gorilla
you look
sensational
i do really do there's nothing wrong
with looking pasty is it i mean i think
no i mean you're pale yes you're a pet
you i'm a white man you make mike pence
look like a character in black panther
get your balls tie them with thick
fishing line
and jump off a cliff while your cat's in
a blender and the blender
is being used to brush your teeth you
sarcastic hmong sincerely the entire
gaming community they got together
to craft that statement
i don't understand the airport run
anymore with the event of uber i don't
understand why you've still got to pick
people up from the airport but you do
the money yeah because some people pay
tax and have to get trained
norm mcdonald is here one of the
funniest people ever norm's got a giant
gambling problem he's dropped more coin
in a casino than michael j fox at a
parking meter
it's a [ __ ] roast groaning grown
grown
go hang yourself with that fat string of
bacon in the kitchen you effing d-gen
i think it's short for degenerate but
then on the other hand a lot of people
opt not to wish death on me they just
wanted me to catch a disease
this guy said get cancer
get brain cancer
that jimmy kimmel video is the stupidest
thing i've ever seen get aids jimmy
thank you there goes mad tv yeah
you're never going to be on show
dude i was at matt tv and michael chase
give me a tour quit bragging
[Laughter]
there was a jumanji league of
superheroes and when you were black adam
karen was nebula and jack was nacho
libre who would kevin be
beat
he'd be honky pete what would his
superpowers be i'd be black adam look at
a honky pete
[Laughter]
this is how this guy defended watching
videos about video games he said why
watch porn when you can go have sex
hey
exactly why would you watch porn when
you realize that
thank you fluffy guy 958
anyway
[Applause]
i'm standing on a bridge between
my forgiveness and your sins
if you wanna
[Music]
you know you know they had to create an
imax just for the two movies that he
made there's two
there's two movies
north macdonald's so stoned he thinks
he's at a roast for bob seger
i love you norm
wow you never come out knowing like the
jd salinger of dick jokes
so you've made so many films in the last
few years have you ever thought of just
slowing down and making just one good
one oh
jimmy jimmy you're like the pumpkin
spice latte see you're a little too
sweet but the white people love you it's
one of those weird things
[Applause]
see over under tonight what's going to
happen norm no i wanted to read
something funny so i'm reading myrmaduke
oh my god this is what happens when you
book a deus off craigslist
mountain lions running through the
streets is that what you want no joe you
[ __ ] lunatic
somebody gets in my face that might
cause me to get more
lunatic i eat a little bit of protein
you had to beat the [ __ ] out of people
for like three decades before you could
like chill
smoke a little weed
put on your little rascals hat and just
[ __ ] chill out
the movies for grown-ups award for best
actor and it goes to adam sandler
[Applause]
you don't come up yet what's wrong with
you
how long have you been in show business
that was sad
you heard your name and you were like
i hesitated to take a pause
in comedy you take pauses
you were like a chimp that saw banana
you came running
the hell was that
[Applause]
we get to you
unbelievable
unbelievable
i'm sorry with jimmy kimmel dude a bow
bow i get it i'm upset with jimmy kimmel
for real you know who that is yeah yeah
james the talk show host kimmel yeah
james james k jk jk
yeah yeah good old jimmy yeah uh
yeah yeah so i went on a show i was he
was fortunate enough he invited me on um
you know his late night show i opened up
to him dude i i talked about me missing
my testicle
like it was it was some serious
conversation
yeah no so no bro he went out he went on
a show recently and he made a joke he
said he said he said me and donald trump
are the worst people on earth you
jimmy kimmel honestly jimmy [ __ ] you bro
i'm not there
oh come on now
had i known you fondly call me jk i
never would have said any of that stuff
i'm sorry lp
i really
i didn't mean to
i hope we can be bros again dude i
really do and i'm sorry about your
testicle i forgot about that you know
what to make up for it i'm going to give
you one of my testicles all right or oh
wait a minute
i just thought of something maybe i'll
introduce you to nicki minaj's cousin's
friend